Nick Gordon loses his lawyer ET can  exclusively confirm Gordon's attorney  Bryant green withdrew in November from  the civil case against Gordon regarding  the death of his late girlfriend Bobbi  Kristina Brown who died last July after  being found unconscious in her bathtub  my pain is horrible like my heart hurts  panic attacks according to a source  Gordon and Greene stopped working  together because of a conflict of  interest adding that the case is at a  still point and Gordon is currently  working on everything pro se no criminal  charges have been filed against Gordon  his attorneys have previously called the  wrongful death civil suit slanderous  knee and meritless